as an entrepreneur you have the chance
to turn your vision into a product
people love putting your ideas in front
of users is a great way to learn what
people like and what can do some work
the quicker you build the faster you
learn and prototyping is the best way to
iterate and refine your ideas in rapid
prototyping by Google and Udacity you'll
build fast code list prototypes using
envision tests with real users and get
feedback on your ideas you'll use that
feedback to make quick and insightful
iterations to your design and move
forward with confidence you'll test with
users across the globe in real time and
use their qualitative feedback to hone
in on a better designer dream build and
iterate get to work building your idea
today visit udacity.com/google